c'est un samedi comme les autres c'est
le week-end il fait beau je fais avec ma
copine typhaine et on décide d'acheter
des fleurs pour la soirée car elle
allait me présenter son frère je décide
par marc était un fleuriste juste à côté
de chez nous et je sais pas pourquoi
alors que normalement on fait tout
ensemble
cette fois ci je la laisse partir
acheter des fleurs tout seul et je reste
garer sur mon scooter
je mets la décrire et je l'attends je la
perds de vue et ça m'inquiète
du coup je m'apprête à lui envoyer un
message pour lui demander où elle est et
là c'est le trou noir
c'est le choc le souvenir d'après c'est
moi au sol cinquante mètres plus loin
sur des pavés les bras en croix et je
reprends tout de suite eu connaissance
je regarde le ciel et jure le très fort
et là je vois ma jambe en fait ma jambe
je ne sens plus rien en fait et je
m'aperçois que ma jambe et arraché et là
on fait dans ma tête ça va très très
vite je me dis tout de suite que c'est
fini la pauline d'avant elle est morte
et que il ya une pauline d'après et que
la vie elle sera plus jamais la même
[Musique]
3 voilà
sans chichi
[Musique]
je me retrouve hospitalisé à l'hôpital
militaire de percy puisqu'en fait ce que
j'ai c'est une blessure de guerre tout
simplement la jambe arrachée c'est une
blessure de guerre
j'ai été pris en charge très rapidement
emmené au bloc une des première phrase
que j'ai dite en salle de réveil après
l'accident cc je vais faire les jeux
paralympiques
donc ça a tout de suite été présent dans
ma tête je savais pas encore dans quel
sport mais mais c'est vrai que ça vite
et est l'objectif que je me suis fixé
pour tenir le coup et est allé le plus
loin possible en fait c'est comme si
dans ma tête ça avait fait chewing ça
allait basculer en mode machine de
guerre je vais transformer ce qui vient
de m'arriver
en quelque chose d'autre que juste
l'accident la perte de la jambe à tous
c'est vrai que dit cette phrase je vais
faire les jeux paralympiques
mais après voilà on passe on passe par
toutes les phases inimaginable mois les
premières semaines je vais être très
honnête j'avais plus envie d'être là
j'avais pu en être
j'avais plus envie d'être en vie dans
cet état là en fait tout simplement
parce que je je je m'approprie est plus
ce corps qui n'était plus le mien pour
moi je trouvais ça moche je trouvais ça
pas féminin et même par rapport à ma
compagne je me disais mais comment elle
peut me trouvais encore belle
mais mais comme ça c'est vrai que cette
prothèse pour le moment c'est encore
trop récent pour dire que c'est ma jambe
je parle jamais de ma prothèse comme
étant ma jambe c'est une extension de
moi que je peux plus ou moins ressentir
contrôler mais c'est pas encore ma gens
et je pense pas que ça le soit un jour
malheureusement
la godille
porté par l'entourage par l'amour que me
porte et tiphaine jeu j'ai décidé de
survivre de continuer à vivre en tout
cas pour elle pour mes proches mais au
début je le faisais pas pour moi
aujourd'hui je peux plus être assistante
réalisatrice comme je l'étais avant tout
simplement parce que c'est un métier qui
demande d'être debout pendant des heures
de courir partout puisque encore une
fois on est on est le chef d'orchestre
d'une émission look il faut être sur
tous les fronts et physiquement c'est
physique
en fait et même si j'ai une prothèse ça
ne me permet pas de tenir sur la durée
autant d'heures de travail debout tout
simplement donc je peux plus
physiquement faire ce métier et ça c'est
très douloureux pour moi et c'est encore
pour ça d'ailleurs que je me suis mis à
fond dans le sport pour essayer de
transformer cette frustration de ne plus
pouvoir faire son métier
en quelque chose de positif finalement
[Musique]
dans les moments les plus forts depuis
ses deux ans et ça a été la première
fois que j'ai un marché c'était c'était
dingue
c'était dingue c'est comme si le phénix
renaît de ses cendres c'est la
renaissance est je me lève et je marche
c'est beau c'est beau et j'en ai pleuré
je voulais partager ça avec tiphaine à
ma compagne qui était là sur les lieux
de l'accident et je crois que avant même
de faire mes premiers pas le problème la
première chose que j'ai faite c'est de
la prendre dans mes bras
debout à sa hauteur et symboliquement
moi c'est très fort pour moi parce que
voilà les premiers pas que j'ai fait
c'est les premiers pas du reste de ma
vie